[Music]
peace
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hello everyone my name is kelsey and i'd
like to welcome you to the very first
annapurna interactive showcase
as we enter our sixth year we want to
thank everyone for the overwhelming
amount of support we've received along
the way
and because of that we felt it was time
to share what's next directly with you
today we'll have about 25 minutes of new
game announcements
deeper dives on previously announced
games and short profiles on just a few
of the developers we are really excited
to be working with
we appreciate everyone watching and want
to thank our partners from all over the
world for making this possible
now let's get this started
[Music]
so you're standing in the shadows of
johnson vendetti
huh it ain't so bad
it's just that i guess folks think they
know who i am
where i should be going
hmm have you considered becoming someone
else entirely
someone else entirely
i've decided to create the most
elaborate stage persona the world has
ever seen
okay will you be down for dinner or
having enchiladas
the boy you loved may already be gone
we're going on a ride across the dilated
pupils of the cosmos
the future is yours if you have the
courage to grasp it
[Music]
[Music]
oh baby we'll have you back in time for
breakfast
[Music]
i'm ben esposito in 2018 i released
donut county a wholesome game
designed for kids and adults alike after
that i decided that my next game will
not be for kids or adults
it'll be a game for freaks
[Applause]
[Music]
neon white is a single player
speedrunning fps where you can sacrifice
your guns for godlike parkour moves
you play as white a dead assassin
plucked from hell
as a neon you have 10 days to purge
heaven of a demonic invasion
but you're not alone only the fastest
demon slayer will earn the right to stay
in heaven
as you play white's story you'll have
plenty of opportunities to get to know
the other neons
you could use a soul card's magic to
shoot like a gun or you can discard it
to use its special movement ability
when to shoot and when to discard is up
to you but if you want to go fast you're
going to need to discard your cards
don't be afraid to use them you can't
take cards with you to the next level
here's your handgun discard it to use
elevate which lets you double
jump to attack from above or create new
shortcuts
here's your smg discard it to you stomp
it's
self-explanatory and here we have the
shotgun
discard it to launch yourself like a
fireball
now let's put it together i'll
demonstrate a level for you
neon white is made up of tight hand
design levels that are meant to be
replayed with new things to do as you
gain xp known
as insight you can share level times
with friends or
if you prove yourself you can compete on
the global neon leaderboards
i got a silver you can see i earned some
insight which unlocks a few new features
for this level
not bad but let's see what it looks like
if we play our cards right
piece of cake nah i practiced top metals
improve your neon rank which unlocks
even more missions
it also earns more insight which reveals
hints for shortcuts and a hidden
collectible in every level
each one of these gifts is a mini puzzle
that requires a clever use of card
resources to collect
it's a tattletail toy i know someone who
loves these
let's go find her this is the map of
central heaven
here you'll get new missions and events
where you can spend time with the other
characters
giving gifts you found in your missions
will deepen your relationships which can
lead to
certain encounters
it's not a traditional dating sim but
there's lots of juicy content to unlock
like side quests exploring the
underworld
and hidden memories from your past life
which might change how your story ends
during the 10 days of judgment you'll
find weapons made of human souls
meet angels in the flesh and if you
become the number one demon slayer
they'll give you an ice cream cone
white is coming to nintendo switch and
pc this winter
if you're a freak put it on your steam
wish list on behalf of the team
thank you we'll see you in heaven
hey
[Music]
i'm the studio head at outer loop games
i'm a designer and artist we're in my
backyard in baffle washington
just north of seattle and run my studio
out of my bedroom
so i'd worked with ekka for several
years previously
on different projects and he pitched me
this
game with a bird in it we prototyped
that and pitched it around and that
turned into outer loop i grew up in sri
lanka which is a former burst colony
falcon ages it's a sci-fi game set in a
distant planet but it's loosely based on
anti-colonial sentiment so for this new
game it's an idea i've had for a couple
years while we were making falcon age
i didn't know what exactly what the game
was gonna be but i knew thematically
what we wanted to try to do
and i have a writing partner meg who is
in bangalore it took us a couple years
to figure out the core
idea for the story and the theme and
then we kind of pitch it to the team and
see how they like
it deals closer to some of the themes i
wanted to try to tackle next which is
immigrant culture growing up in the u.s
gossiping aunties and overbearing
parents and family pressure
really the game comes together with the
with the whole crew of 15
and bringing their own specialty myself
and ekka we knew each other back in
california on my first job actually
and then eventually ended up starting
out a loop every game i make the some
aspect of
juggling parkour martial arts
skateboarding we're gonna go skating
this is all hazel that's what he does
right one of my main thing is i want
games to be really
accessible and easy so i've been
skateboarding for about
24 years and i'm terrible at it the tony
hawk
type of games is a break from reality of
what actual skateboarding is and more of
like
the things i actually want to do you
rarely crash in the skateboarding
portion
because i'm trying to make it as
accessible to as many people as possible
in my 20-plus years this has been the
most fun
team i've ever worked on we wanted to
put something out there that's more
reflective of
our live experiences which we feel like
as a game will stand out our process has
been
find a unique theme that's not out there
and then mix it with some more familiar
gameplay
and that's that's what we did with
falcon age and that's what we're doing
with the new game we're really excited
to talk about it
[Music]
the golden of the
[Music]
light earlier once reserved
[Music]
when i was home with you
hold on to your heart
hold on to my love
hold on to the peace
that i'm there
have them
[Music]
um
hi my name is jessica mack i'm a solo
game dev from toronto canada
this is my cat
my parents they started a computer store
this is like in the
early 80s and back then most people
didn't have computers in their homes
but we did and i guess as a side effect
of that i was also
interested in how computers work i would
always tinker with them
and i met a friend who gave me my first
compiler
it just seemed like magic like how did
you even make it not even a video game
but like a program
i started off working alone because
there was nobody else my first game was
solo
and then the second game i collaborated
with the musician
then i took some time to like actually
sit down and
write songs and produce them properly
the music in this game i just feel more
confident about
the analogy i think of is i say you're
writing this song
and you're like we need someone to go
off on the guitar at this point
guitar solo time you can't tell someone
how to do that you just have to have the
instrument in your hand
and you have to feel it and you have to
be like one with it and let it rip
it's the same way with video games
[Music]
the computer is my instrument the
compiler is my instrument
i find i work strongest when i work in
here
when it's just subconscious you're just
flowing in it and you're making
100 decisions a second and then by the
time you come out of it
it's like it almost feels like you're
waking up
with music you can write a song that's
three minutes and 30 seconds
and so much happens in it every eight
bars it's like it's something new
something new something new
that's sort of the density that i want
to put in this game
music that can move you on such a
visceral level is
super interesting to me and so all my
games
are music focused the music
for me is very much as important as the
game part of it
itself this time with this game
it is an adventure game but it's action
but there's like this musical component
to it
when people play it they won't know what
to expect
i want to make an engaging experience
but not an addictive experience
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
what's the one with the um where you
have to guess who the little cartoon
people are stratego
is that it no
[Music]
well hi there hello my name is davey
reed
i was the creator of the stanley parable
and the beginner's guide i'm carla
zamanja
i was co-creator of gone home in tacoma
and
we uh started a studio it's true it's
called ivy road
we're working together we're making a
video game we're working with annapurna
to make
a totally unannounced game that we can't
talk about yet we are very very lucky to
get to be joined by our good friend
daniel rosenfeld aka c418
the musician from minecraft and speaking
of daniel is actually
composing the music that you're hearing
right now at this very moment let's go
to him
hey there oh hey no no sorry i didn't no
no i don't want to you're good you're
good i just i'm just
for the people just saying you know hey
so can we give them a treat no no
no no don't don't feed them that's all
right we'll leave them alone cheers yeah
cheers
oh ow who eaten this tea we are both
super excited about ivy road
and uh about the thing that we are
working on together that we can't talk
about
uh all we can really talk about is each
other right now so i
wrote a couple questions to ask you to
kind of get to know you a little bit
better to find out more for
for the people at home and about sort of
our studio culture and what that's like
so question number one if you really are
a true gamer
name 10 000 games oh man
well i mean honestly there's like uh
final fantasy one through ten thousand
okay actually that's i didn't expect her
to get that right
a bus leaves atlanta at 10 30 a.m
traveling west
at 55 miles an hour okay why
you don't want to leave atlanta uh last
question for you here
uh why do kids love the taste of
cinnamon toast crunch
you know i understand that child
psychologists have been debating this
for like
decades you know there's two schools of
thought well that's all the time we have
today thank you very much for joining us
for this discussion of the
studio values of ivy road and the things
that we care about let's cut to daniel
let's cut to daniel
[Music]
cheers cheers
[Music]
[Music]
so you've decided to be an insurance
commando
pirates are kidnapping cats from our
ships
luckily the cats bought our deluxe
insurance package
you your mission
eradicate the pirates by any means
necessary
[Applause]
protocol 127.1 no bullets
no problem
[Music]
protocol 832 being smelly and what to do
about it
oh no you're making smell clouds
you're so dirty a space pirates smell
[Music]
you wash your whole body
[Music]
beware of blades protocol 999
whisk not want not
[Applause]
skin deep wish list now on steam or
blendogames.com
and remember if you screw up it's not
the end
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
hi there
how do you do it
[Music]
have
[Music]
hello everyone my name is swan producer
at blue12 studio
and today i'm going to show you more
about stray
[Music]
in stray you play as a cat who has
fallen inside the mysterious and
forgotten city
separated from his family and injured he
will have to explore and survive in this
unwelcoming environment
[Music]
from the cat's unique point of view
players must navigate their way through
the dangers of this unfriendly place
and use the cat's skills to solve
puzzles and uncover mysteries along the
way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
along his journey the cat will meet a
small drone named b12
[Music]
using the drone's ability to interact
with objects in the world
and communicate with the strange
inhabitants of this secluded place
together they will work to learn more
about the secrets of this forgotten
community
of human-like machines
[Music]
so
[Music]
of course the cat will always be a cat
and his adventures will be filled with
friendly and playful interactions with
his new world
[Music]
but these machines are not the only
inhabitants of the city
and some encounters will not be as
friendly
running fast jumping and using spells to
avoid dangers
will all be vital if you want to escape
this city and be reunited with family
[Music]
[Music]
unless you find a way to defend yourself
and the prey might become the hunter
stray is coming to ps4 ps5 as well as pc
in early 2022 and we can't wait to show
you more
[Music]
uh
[Music]
me
it's funny no codes i think we've kind
of
got the name of being a horror game dev
and for every game we've made we've
never set out to make a horror game
we've set out to make thrillers or
atmospheric sci-fi it sounds like you're
making that noise
we release it and everyone's like that
was terrifying
we've pretty much known each other since
the third year of primary school
i'd be around at john and graeme's house
so they'd be around at mine you kind of
think back and you go oh yeah i was
never really a big horror fan and then
you think actually that's all we watched
i think maybe graeme or omar got the
aliens director's cut and so just every
thursday for about a year
after school it went on we're always
very close playing in bands together
i think there always has been that sort
of creative drive to sort of work on a
project
between us all and so this in many ways
feels very natural
i always knew if if i was going to start
something
i'd probably do it with omar or graham
or both making games as a job
i wouldn't have believed my older self
we'd be doing this
and working on the projects that we've
worked on so far
personally for me no code and it's not
because i'm working here but they are
one of the most exciting studios in
scotland by far and i've always sort of
had in the back of my head that if i was
ever going to
jump ship it would be to join them it's
incredibly encouraging to see where we
could go
both as a company but i think what we
could do for the city of glasgow as well
so we're working on a a new project you
know this project's gonna
like our biggest project to date and
obviously we've we've scaled the team up
we've doubled in size
it's something that i didn't think we'd
really get a chance to work on you know
like something we'd be able to do in our
career it's one of these opportunities
that come up and you just kind of you
have to move along with it you know
we're taking
what we do and what we love and trying
to push it to the next stage with a
bigger budget
and a little bit more time we've never
really set out to make a horror game
but we've kind of ended up in that
whereas this game we are setting out to
make a horror game i don't think
anyone's expecting what we're going to
do next
which makes it even more exciting
[Music]
hey folks alex from mobius here just
wanted to give you a brief update on
what we've been up to behind the bale of
shadows first off mobius and unity have
partnered together
and are working hard to bring outer
wilds to the nintendo switch
we look forward to having it in your
hands this holiday season
we are also very excited to officially
announce that we're making an expansion
for outer wilds
and it's going to weave directly into
the existing world and narrative
now if you've played the game you might
be wondering how
and also why and those are very good
questions
okay without further ado we hope you
enjoy this willfully cryptic trailer for
outer wild's first
and only expansion
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
thank you so much for watching our first
showcase we hope you enjoyed the sneak
peek into the world of annapurna
interactive
until next time
[Music]
cheers
you